right before the pandemic you were on
broadway you were doing a play so you
were nominated for the tony you went to
the tonys you didn't win the tony were
you upset no i'm i'm a grown up um i'm
not gonna say that or at least i try and
act like one you know and right um i
have people i admire who
i i try and emulate um
and in that case i think
i don't know
uh
i'm not gonna say i wanna win you know
of course that's the first first time in
my life i probably would say that i want
to win i put a lot of hard work into
that thing you know right it started as
an idea like a random idea it was a
monologue about death and then all of a
sudden we
sh sold out a show on broadway for 11
weeks and we got into prophets and
two monologues about death you know and
then
and then we got nominated for four tonys
and the other show i produced we got
nominated for 12. we were 16 tom is
amazing so did i want to win sure but
i don't really
i was so i know andrew who won the kid
who won i mean the great thing about him
he used to help me run lines he used to
come really to my office and help me run
lines for for a couple things andrew
that sometimes yeah you were telling me
this [ __ ] kid beat you for the tone
what the hell it was amazing i mean when
he went up i i i threw my arms around
him i was so excited for him that's what
i would do that's the moment
act all happy throw your arms around the
kid hey you know what i mean but i would
i'd be seething